I'm here with Hans and Simon is that
right what you want to you know what
France electrons that's your what are
your your Dietrich your assignment Simon
puns hans those funds trust then i've
had a lot of these they want to learn
traditional Bavarian dance you guys are
experts we are you are brothers this is
the what is that happening now there's a
vast year this is like sort of a
leprechaun thing and then you can Selita
hosen now their bondage shorts the socks
and it's called loofah
so that's German for pieces of socks
what's going on here you've got two
spoons in your pocket what do you use
those for
[Applause]
what a musician with you
appreciate you leaving your cuckoo clock
to be here because ESA zing
in German zing right yeah you guys have
worked together before
yes are you their father no one told me
that you just find out that as your
father Maury Povich I just have a swig
after that I think I should begin
wearing some dance we're gonna learn
some what kind of dancing is are called
schuhplattler schuhplattler who can't
learn the schuhplattler when you don't
look like a Bavarian grouper start Ameer
let us begin
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we even without steam bond ow long since
I'd be bald in dish we're going to show
you what you got yourself into okay
[Music]
I'm not like your sons you have beat me
with a wooden stick like we dance I
didn't want this this is what they
wanted they wanted to work with
computers say can do Bulls come on guys
monster for you 1 2 3 4 1 2 fancy for
that pom-pom well no I mean close enough
no sir please closer
so 1 2 3 Cory Hamza yeah you knew where
my hands were don't be a hog where are
they I think we know where they are
how come you have no accent I don't
understand what's happening
first of all you are I mean clearly you
were carved out of a sausage
so you seem like a German guy and this
guy's like dude let's catch some rays
what's happened to him do you know Billy
Joel's the piano man yeah I've heard
about lovely time my dad I'm just happy
new Billy Joel's later this book sends
the phone
[Laughter]
[Music]
so you play you stir it a little early
it's a chance to be in the right spot so
come in come on
does he ever admit he's wrong one
recommendation group therapy with your
two sons you say no therapy let's just
keep with this insane scheme of yours to
make your children dance and dance and
dance until the grave ready just one
suggestion well don't spread to your
fingers like this
we know you have ten fingers
[Music]
[Applause]
well I'm pretty good you don't you know
I'm only in town for a couple days I
think this is pretty good
now I know I'm not by this guy standards
certainly a few things which we could
improve
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Safina clips I mean literally you were
born your dad squeeze you into some
leather pants started hitting them with
the spoons and making you live out this
sick dream and now you're ganging up on
me I don't like it I want to bring in
someone who's the most German guy I know
could you come in here please egauge
boys well this is the only place I can
really be in my natural state without
breaking up too many marriages this is
like the reason you put a bell on a cat
because of your German roots I think
this is gonna come very nice all right
let's give it a try okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you condone this weather on brother
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay Oh enjoyed watching that I'm
slapping each other's asses that is hot
of so-so
oh yeah part of your little show isn't
it I know what you've been doing and it
stops now
[Music]
[Applause]
you